I'm so happy my mom pushed on me she
would always tell me don't get a tattoo
always always when I was younger I would
be like Mom you're so judgmental why are
you so judgmental and now I say thank
you Mom I have zero tattoos and I am I'm
very proud of it because I keep seeing
all these beautiful chicks ruining their
beauty with ink then you know if
say there aren't men that will accept it
but by and large men don't like that
sort of thing so they did a poll on
Jason Holmes men and men you prefer
debt-free virgins without tattoos I'm
trying to see how accurate her role is
in her State 70 said yes it's 16 said I
don't mind and 14 so I'm not at
so 16 that I don't mind seventy percent
said I'm right on the money and and this
kind of you know goes into society
because it's like what at the bottom of
thirty percent of men